awesome I think was supposed to be
sensual with just at you and then it was
taking on no League East and then I put
on an X and that looked cool and then I
just went on with it the first time I
played was where with some friends
actually a wondrous cousin I went to
class with he introduced me to it and I
thought it was a pretty fun game I
didn't really play much games back then
so I was mainly out outside playing
football or soccer or whatever you want
to call it so it wasn't a bit of a
different experience for me it was
something that I sub set microfone from
like CSUN and css3 I think when I played
on the Danish team and we I think with
Wonder and Wonder play jungle actually
and we won against all the good Danish
team at that time and then like I got
offered from an international teams with
some of the best Danish players at that
time like other than quite a lot there
and then I said my goal for going for
the second assassin to the next target
wild growth available he manages to
channel it this time the Ignite is
taking flash for flash sync ax gets the
kill I come from a football family my
uncle was a playing professional
football so it was a bit harsh in the
beginning my mom wasn't really for it
she was like needs to go outside you
need to go play football yeah you need
to do some sports anything I think until
I actually like shorter that you could
earn something doing this earned money
doing this that then she got more like
into it and she is more supportive now
and my whole family is very supportive
and my friends are so and always been
supporting me
I think in the springs width of
challenge series I played pretty well
that speck compared to the other
challenging teams and I had a lot of
good games there but towards the end of
the summer sphere I would even say at
the beginning I was doing pretty well as
well going to help out for the
additional kill kill dead cuts
we need to cease and Koch's pick up
speed again because at least if they
were if they win or lose him okay it's
gonna upset the ceilings put for
playoffs for sure
same cooks has to pick it up because if
he doesn't then I mean players chances
are gonna plummet the whole offseason up
to the LCS I could have played a lot
more and I should have done it and I
should have practiced a lot harder and
that's why I would say company into the
earth yes I wasn't a player that people
expected me to be qualified for the LCS
at the Dignitas EU after beating
mousesports then sold to follow esports
then rebranded a splice could be a dark
horse so nice wind on Yamato garden and
me we started learning stuff that we've
never thought about before I knew that
this was not gonna be the best for us
because we had a lot to learn like we
were completely new to the whole macro
play we just knew how to group myth and
throw us pills and play a team for it
and that's what we were good at that was
team fighting right so we had to work on
a lot of stuff and I feel like it was
just an experience especially for myself
I feel like I played pretty bad in most
games and I could have done a lot more
and I feel like this but I'm just trying
to improve myself and we're trying to
improve as a team and we're doing pretty
well obviously like in the beginning
it's like the fundamentals we had to
work on and we got that down and then we
start working on the small details and
every single scenario what would happen
and we know this and that and we can do
this and that then we brought in Micky X
and this
he's a very different player from this
but I would say so it was a big of a bit
of a difference but in terms of the
macro player all of us four players to
know what that has to be done and I feel
like we learned so much the last bit
that it it's obviously worth it knowing
that we can compete compete with
everything
huge victory from the boys front splice
I would say we're really like maybe a
small Brotherhood you could say like
yeah we're pretty trollee towards each
other like we've known each other was
super long everyone except Micky
probably because season it's not Danish
it's not from the the best country so
but I've known wonder from like four or
five years now because I've went to
class with his cousin and we pretty much
grow friendship through deke like and
then I've known Cobra for two or three
years now and I've played with different
teams with him and try chef noon since I
played on recent games so it's like four
players that I've known for really long
time that I feel comfortable around that
we can talk about things and we can
troll around and do what everyone
you